I have some new tour dates to announce
uh I will be in Toronto Ontario August
31st at the Elgin Theater Lincoln
Lincoln California on September 15th uh
Las Vegas Nevada on October 27th and
28th Milwaukee Wisconsin September 8th
San Jose California September 14th
and Washington D.C on October 21st at
the theater at MGM National Harbor all
tickets are available at theovan.com
t-o-u-r thank you for your support
today's guest is a rapper from Los
Angeles he's out of Compton
California
um
he's one you know he got he has he has
he's got some hits he's got some bangers
you know he'll put it together for you
he'll put that anthem on that'll bring
the babies get the heads bobbin
and um
you know he's an actor he's an
entrepreneur
uh he's doing a lot of different things
and I'm just grateful to chop it up with
them today's guest is Mr YG
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
a lot of brothers seem like they got
that cologne built into them
that's what I need yeah my [__] is
different really yeah my [__] different
what's happening man what it do bro it's
popping not much just um excited to
spend time with you today thanks for
coming in thanks for having me though
um so for some of my listeners that
won't know about you right so you grew
up in California yeah yeah and um what
was y'all's neighborhood like growing up
oh man oh
I grew up like in multiple different you
know I'm saying places
um
but it was a
it was like shootouts
[__] going on like that
um
sunspots was chilling in the other
you know I'm saying it was robberies
going on a lot heavy in one spot
I hate robberies
we was doing them though so it was
different
I guess if you yeah if you on the
receiving end of it you was different
though like a little bit different yeah
in these uh
in these apartments
was it fun or not was it scary or was it
fun no it was all fun it was yeah that'd
be the crazy thing bro like
a lot of people there grow up you know
what I'm saying living like you send me
the ghetto dangerous life
like a lot of us think it's fun
yeah I'm saying and then when you make
it out
and then you start looking back he's
like damn I was playing with fire like
the whole time like it'd be crazy yeah
that's what seems interesting sometimes
it's like uh it seems like this the
it seems like Grand Theft Auto sometimes
yeah you know whenever whenever you get
out of that space and you get into like
a like a
I guess probably they probably look at
it as like a fancier way of living or
you make it out right dude though
do those people look differently at you
then is that kind of
oh I mean it depends on
your story you know what I'm saying and
how you came up and made it out and um
like you know you always gonna have a
group of people that's speaking like
down on you you know what I'm saying
negative comments but
um like when you did it like
you know I'm saying like the right way
or like you know I'm saying you can't be
solid you say you're gonna have a lot of
people that's like championing your name
you know yeah
um oh yeah that's I can see that dude
like like like like my story like you
know I'm saying if you from L.A
like if you from Los Angeles County you
know what I'm saying you know YG story
you know what I'm saying and uh you can
use like you probably damn near feel
like you know YG you know
um
so I feel like me making it out
still being out here you know what I'm
saying having success and still doing it
I feel like like a lot of people like
you know I'm saying they um support
they look up to it they support it they
can relate yeah for sure you know what
I'm saying they've seen the whole come
up right
do they have Halloween in like the hood
or whatever do they have Halloween in
the hood or yeah there's Halloween
everywhere
uh it's dangerous though really I mean
Halloween is a night you can get away
with
doing crime because everybody wearing
costumes and masks and [__] like that so
you know yeah you can't have a police
lineup with [__] Dracula in it Super
Mario
that's gonna uh nobody's gonna know did
anything exactly you can't call and say
a Pokemon just [__] held me up yeah
um what is like the best holiday in uh
in like the hood what is the best
holiday you think
the
Fourth of July yeah
that should be tough really
block parties everywhere yeah
barbecues barbecues block party
fireworks it's like four parties going
on you hitting like four parties in one
day you know what I'm saying it's like
Memorial Day
Fourth of July
Labor Day weekend so that kind of day is
a bigger day and then like kind of a
traditional holiday probably are you now
you asked what's the best holiday in the
hood like you know what I'm saying like
the other holidays like you with your
family in the house right you know what
I'm saying
um or the three holidays I just name is
like you outside yeah you know what I'm
saying so like
like on some hood [__] like yeah those
gonna be the best of the holidays you
know yeah I would like
I think sometimes I would like to go to
some of those parties you know yeah no
the party's broke you know what I'm
saying be lit
be lit you know what I'm saying like I
stopped doing like the wild ghetto you
take the day off for that parties no no
no no no no hell no I still wait what
you mean like would you would people
take the day off of
um
like doing
CR you know I don't want to say crime or
whatever but do people take the day off
and just everybody is that a truce and
everything's chill like on a memorial
day or fourth of July you don't know you
get your brains flat bro you're at the
wrong place at the wrong target
wrong group of people you know what I'm
saying you get seen by the wrong person
some like it's bad damn bro some [__]
freeze tagging that [__] y'all playing
huh
these like I mean
I'm chilling but you know
when you left when you moved out of
there did you have to like have a formal
meeting with everybody and be like hey
guys I just want you to know no like
bro I was living like like I was living
in Inglewood
for
for a minute like
but I was like when I started like
having success like I was living in
Inglewood
like this smack in the middle for the
ghetto and everybody knew where I lived
at
like yeah you know what I'm saying and
uh
you know I'm saying I was having like
songs on the radio doing all type of
leaving out of town going on tour my mom
and him at the house
you know what I'm saying
um
well yeah when I got up out of here
like I just got on
I went to the valley
damn I went to the valley but I left the
valley because I'm like this [__] weak
the valley was hell yeah yeah it's a lot
of ubereats and [__] out there no this
is like you feel me this like
2013. oh yeah you know what I'm saying
[Music]
[Laughter]
like Huntington Beach or something damn
yeah bro I was all over the place like
my whole life out here I've been all
over the place like
do you think uh
man I would love what do you think you
ever do like a Christmas album
a Christmas album yeah
I mean I feel like you feel that would
be kind of weird for me you know
I don't I mean I don't think it would be
I don't I think if I did it Christmas um
like my [__] would be like it'd be like
my [__] would be like called like ho ho
ho you know yeah yeah
like Rudolph the Red-nosed yeah you
gotta my [__] would be about the [__]
yeah I'm saying oh yeah it's beginning
to look like these [__] are showing
up yeah I could see something like that
see I would love if there was like kind
of like uh I bet you could pull some
anthems though out of like a Christmas
album man
maybe you know I'm trying to think of
something else um
I'm dreaming of a red bone [__] with a
long-ass braid
we gotta take you to the studio I mean
I'm just trying to think I would just
I've never seen a Christmas album that
had you know that really had some
[__] fire in it you know Mariah did
that one and that one was good but
there's nothing that's nobody's really
come up and pulled up at Christmas with
that [__] Banger boy it was like some
gangster [__] yeah that's what I want
you know you like gangster music I want
to see somebody [__] shoot up a
snowman you know
um I like some of it like when I was
growing up like Lil Wayne was I grew up
in New Orleans so or outside of New
Orleans so like juvenile who else Little
Wayne Uh partners in crime mystical
uh cash money was huge then hell yeah
dude cash money used to go come to the
gym at LSU and uh it was like Silk and
Master P and he would they would have
these other dudes stand on the side and
hold their clothes for whenever they got
done playing
just some dudes like just standing there
like they were like a coat rack just
holding their shoes and clothes
um
so what kind of motive like like so when
do you when does music really start to
kind of take off for you and were you
always musically inclined or did that
come with like through school through
friends
oh
I mean I grew up you know what I'm
saying
my family like my mama and my pops my
like everybody around
you know what I'm saying with heavy hip
hop rap
um
r b you know what I'm saying family you
know what I'm saying that's all we like
like listen to but um like in high
school is when I started rapping though
like I started rapping in high school
and like
like my homies that I went to school
with you know what I'm saying like Lumi
since then
you feel maybe like bro since you
started you had it wow it was just like
you know I'm saying like I always made
music that people like party to you know
what I'm saying so when I started off
and I was just like a rookie trash I
thought I was weak as [__] he said me
the homies was like nah this [__] hard
we partying and [__] like you feel me so
like I don't know bro but uh so it was
just a gift you think
yeah do you think do you look at it as a
gift
do you look at it as like a no no no no
no no you don't show gifted for sure
for show gifted
um
yeah it's a gift you know what I'm
saying like I just had to work on a
couple things you know
and would they let you like in school
would they let you do it or do you or do
you mostly to start to produce stuff
with friends
what you mean in school let me do it
like do they say like you start coming
up with lyrics Right say you got like
you got Rhymes You Got lyrics you got
bars you do what's the next thing you
have to get how do you do you may also
make your own beats or do you get Matt
stuff with a beat maker what's that like
and how hard is that you know I was
trying to make my own beats and [__] at
first and [__]
I couldn't get I couldn't [__] with the
program and
I just couldn't get with it and [__] so
uh I started just rapping on on other
beats like how Lil Wayne was doing and
[__] I was on like LimeWire and all that
[__] downloading she's pulling beats
down you like rapping on [__] like that
yeah and then um
probably like a year later I started
meeting like [__] that made
beats and [__] on on MySpace
and [__] um
and then yeah like I started having my
like like original songs and [__]
and um
like outside of that like would help
like me
like navigate and like end up popping
off
you know I'm saying out the city was you
know I'm saying I was like in the
streets and [__] and I had like a
movement going on at a young age
and I had like a gang of [__]
and we was all from the same click
it was like some young High School
it was like High School
fresh out of high school ghetto ass the
kid [__] you know what I'm saying and um
you know that Movement Like helped me
like navigate through the city like like
everybody was talking about like why is
it
and uh yeah
did y'all have any weaponry
hell yeah yeah
bro like like I came up
like in the club
like outside
at a young age doing all the outside
[__] you see me we was doing all the
street [__] yeah but then we was
partying we like it was the party it was
the party crew but then at the party you
know what I'm saying like I used to go
to all the parties and like you know I
used to be like
like gangbang you know at the parties in
the parties you know I'm saying we'll
have a whole bunch of like [__]
from the other side type [__] and so
they're they're back they and those are
the guys you gotta get those guys no
it's just we'll start getting into it in
the party you know what I'm saying yeah
I'm banging my [__] they banging they
[__] we like so what uh uh and then
it'll just start going up it'll be
fights it'll be shootouts all that type
of [__]
and you um you figured out what's
happening like every other weekend [__]
yeah dang that's like a what like a
that's like the wild west man yeah well
you know what I'm saying when you like
bro when you come in L.A and you young
and [__] that's bro that [__] is regular
damn yeah
and how do you get into a gang do you
have to like apply or anything or how do
you you gotta I mean you got to get
jumped on you know what I'm saying you
gotta that's you applying I guess you
got to get what yeah you got to get
jumped on by like multiple [__]
you know and what do you even wear to
something like that
maybe I had on man what I had them
when I got put on I had like a long ass
white T-shirt and some skinny jeans oh
yeah
uh not skinny though at the time you see
me they would have called him skinny at
that time yeah
and do you are you allowed to defend
yourself during that or no that's not
part of it hell yeah you better damn
I don't know if I could do it bro no you
can't fight I can yeah so you good I
don't know though I can't fight that
good oh I can't you can't yeah do you
miss it sometimes what fun yeah I mean
just because now your life is a little
different you know you don't have to
fight as much I mean you don't have to
battle every day
you know what I'm saying
now it's like [__] don't fight
no more you know I know yeah it's
changed a lot huh it's changed a lot
yeah people trying to follow people huh
people unfollow people oh yeah that's
their you know it's like it's definitely
a lot different
do you look at the younger generation be
like damn these cats got it easy
or do you think they just have enough I
just think it's different because
like
when I was a young [__] the
[__] older than us
like
we hate to hear like all the
[__] got it easy like nah like
you sound like a hater
you know what I'm saying it's just
different like time is changing you know
yeah
and what other Weaponry would y'all use
only guns or any would people have some
like uh
bats or
Knuckles bows no that's NWA type [__]
yeah it wasn't like that you know we
wouldn't have no fashion [__] you know
what I'm saying what
um what's the best type of weapon for a
hold up do you think
for who for like a hold up you're gonna
hold somebody up you're gonna stick
somebody up for rob somebody yeah rob
somebody if you're going to rob somebody
what's the best
what do you think
oh a pistol yeah
[__] scared of that oh yeah oh
if I see a pistol I get scared sometimes
my arms won't move
like I lock up you know damn
um
you got shot before yeah damn bro I
always wanted to get shot huh
I always wanted to just to feel it just
in my leg or something I never wanted to
take something in the chest you know
oh crazy bro but I always wanted to feel
careful what you wish for though
yeah maybe we'll take that part
no leave it in there all right you're
gonna take it back you got to talk to
the man up there he said you know what
man
yeah I was just having a good time I
didn't really mean that [__] uh yeah
that's true I need to bring that up
but yeah I always want to I think I you
know you always always want to have
experiences that I never had I never got
to smoke crack I've never been shot and
bro you can go smoke crack like I know I
know but now it's like I don't drink or
anything now so I feel like I would
really have to go back into that space
like if you want some crack let me know
I can get you something really yeah damn
you know people that smoke it I know
people that got it yeah
oh so let me know what you want to do
okay
um take me through that experience of
getting shot man is it okay if I ask you
about it
do you
know y'all talked about it before
like what you mean take your experience
like like did you were you expecting to
get shot or it was a surprise
it was kind of a surprise
like you know I'm saying I knew it was
like some [__] going on
put on
like
like I ran out
trying to like you know what I'm saying
shrana
trying to do something and then I ended
up getting shot oh yeah
and where did it hit you at the bullet
it hit me
my hip and then like
stomach like you know like
pubic hair [__] yeah yeah dude like damn
right there on a dick like on top of it
bro I got like three bullet holes and
[__] you still got the bullets in you no
no no
damn
damn bro and did it hurt
yeah that sure heard it yeah all right
well my [__] was like it's like all
flush if I didn't hit no bone or nothing
none of that so like you know what I'm
saying like
my [__] could have been worse way worse
yeah
and did you go to the doctor you have a
friend take it out no I went to the
hospital I went to the hospital
dang bro that's heavy man did you feel
like it gave you more Street Credit
after that like at that point do you
feel like man I think
at this point we paid our dues you know
I don't like getting shot don't give you
Street Credit
like or the [__] is doing the
shooting to get the streets ready
damn but like
like the situation that happened
like
the [__] Who start shooting
they end up
getting chased up up out of there you
know what I'm saying yeah
and whatever happened to them did you
ever see them again or see them
either online or anything
nah we still be trying to figure out
like who the [__]
boy bro
y'all saying that's the coldest [__]
ever yeah it is because you know I'm
saying now it's like
you just on on you got your guard up at
all times because you don't know
you coming across people like and it's
already like you would like have some
weird Vibes with somebody
and then you would be just you just
thinking like is this [__]
something to do with that [__] you know
yeah
oh yeah man yeah
I could see that easy being kind of like
suspecting everybody a little bit dang
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
that's right
I've gotten therapy I've gotten better
help
um you know I've had times where I
wasn't seeing
the world as comfortably as I should be
you know and it wasn't just a little
thing it wasn't just something that I
knew would pass it was something that
was building and gaining momentum inside
of me and it kind of scared me
you know if you're struggling if there's
something that's off it's
behind me we're humans
we have a voice and we need to use that
and we need to get feedback from someone
who knows what they're talking about
Better Health can help set you up with a
licensed professional
that's right it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time there's no charge
and I want to iterate that if if you are
going to a therapist and it's super
comfortable and easy
but nothing's changing then that might
not be the best scenario
you can always try a new one here or
there you can go back to the first one
if you want
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's right that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp
when you um
when you look at music for you now like
how has it kind of evolved how is rap
evolved for you since you first started
like when you look at making a new
project
um
how's it because you've had a good
Vision I feel like at this point you've
had a good vision of the industry you
know you've had a lot of experience
you've also
um what does it look like when you kind
of was trying to put something new
together
I'll be talking about a song or a
project a project like a whole album
Maybe or even just a song it could be
anything I mean for a project it depends
on what type of project like I'm trying
to make like
like
um
like like like like like
when is she coming out
um I'm not sure but we can make it come
out whenever
all right so like me and tiger working
on a a project right now you know what
I'm saying in the approach is just like
we just talking [__] we having fun you
know I'm saying it ain't no pressure it
ain't no it's not no deep thinking none
of that type of [__] is just like you
know what I'm saying we linking up we
vibing out we doing music we partying we
doing all this [__] you know what I'm
saying we're creating a body work right
you know I'm saying that's one approach
oh yeah that's like mixtape Vibes you
know
and then you have to you know I'm saying
you got the uh
you got the real
you got the conceptual albums like
approach you know what I'm saying and
that should get a little different you
know what I'm saying that [__] like you
bring a white boy the whiteboards out
you bring a notepads out you know what
I'm saying
it's a lot of sitting plotting you know
I'm saying you listening to
whatever your favorite albums might be
or whatever type of [__] you're trying
to do you you know I'm saying you
getting inspiration you watching movies
you know what I'm saying you're watching
whatever you it's it's deep it's intense
you know what I'm saying and and like
you know I'm saying those is like the
two different
um type of album process that I've been
doing you know I'm saying since I've
been rapping this [__]
well
you've had works in the past I heard you
talk about that you just your ownership
of your stuff you know like your
ownership of your Masters I guess and of
your like just your work right which I
think is huge right it's one of the
reasons why I podcast so that I don't
have to work for anybody right and
um and I think the audience loves that
they love that they know this is
nobody's cutting this you know nobody
has a hand in on this except for the
person who's the creator you know
um what's that like for you because I
know you I mean I've I've listened to
you talk about it a little bit
but where does that kind of come from
you think
because some people don't care
oh
so I just got like my ownership and all
that [__] like recently like you know
what I'm saying probably like
probably like last year you know what
I'm saying uh like my music moving
forward type [__] which is uh it is what
it is but you know what I'm saying
my [__] me caring about that
um
me caring about it
it's like now I'm growing [__] like you
know what I'm saying so it's like
this is normal you know I'm saying
that's how we moving like you know what
I'm saying you hit a certain age and you
start realizing certain [__] but like
y'all I'm saying I start caring about
the [__] before I was older because like
Nipsey had a lot to do with that you
know what I'm saying like
um
nip used to like
he would preach that he would preach
that [__] like bro he'll preach that
[__] crazy like wow like like yeah like
bro get crazy and then the brand [__]
like creating your own brand you know
what I'm saying how to live on longer
than you you know what I'm saying he was
like he was pushing that line and all
that and you know you see me that's when
I created my 400 brand and [__] and uh
yeah that's like probably one of the
best things I ever did you know
um and I own that fully like on that
bank owning that yeah so
um that's huge you know what I'm saying
I was on that [__]
like back in the day like 25 26 but like
my deal
you know what I'm saying I signed when I
was 19. you know I was like yeah I just
got out that [__] like
like like like 2021 type [__] so
um now now with my music yeah like you
feel me on the music side of [__] yeah
if you feel more inspired because now
you can work just for yourself yeah
getting off for sure I'm exploring I
feel like I left a whole lot of money on
the table I gotta go you know what I'm
saying dig that [__] up bring that [__]
back yeah
um so yeah I'm inspired for show for the
show
that's amazing man it's so crazy yeah
because so many people don't realize
like
you need help to get places right you
need sometimes like you have to be able
to let somebody you almost have to pay
your dues a little bit sometimes right
like I remember when I would go to clubs
the club owner used to get most of the
money from the ticket sales right until
a certain point when I was selling
tickets finally I was like no we need to
change this or I'm not just not even
going to do it I'll build my I'd rather
build my own club exactly and just so
I'm gonna go to a club around the corner
who gonna give me the deal I want right
I'm gonna bring all these people to that
club yeah [__] your Club yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
um but yeah I think having ownership I
think probably seems like it'd be real
empowering yeah and then that [__]
Jay-Z you know I'm saying he like like
you know what I'm saying he the reason
why everybody is on that [__] oh really
yeah cause
been preaching that [__] you know I'm
saying back in the 90s all the way until
now so like we all grew up hearing that
[__] you know what I'm saying right on
your [__] yeah on your [__] ownership
and then like watching like everybody
who been in the game you know what I'm
saying 10 20 years before us and [__]
and looking at all they moves it's like
bro that [__] is in us now like yeah you
know what I'm saying it's blocked in
yeah yes yeah because it's such a genre
I mean especially I mean rap music is
really and Hip-Hop is a black genre kind
of a music right so to think that they
wouldn't have ownership of their [__] is
really [__] unreal I mean yeah but
it's the music business thing you know
what I'm saying right it's a musical
music business right you know what I'm
saying we created the the hip-hop rap
um a little [__] you know what I'm
saying branch of the [__] but we didn't
create the movement right you didn't
create yeah who owns the speakers who
owns the uh the radio stations all of
that you're the [__] distribution how
you putting the [__] out you know what
I'm saying
yeah there's always an owner it seems
like man of course
that [__] [__] makes me mad bro
I hate that [__] I always wanted to do
entirely my own thing I mean you doing
it now bro yeah you're right I need to
calm down
I gotta kill a little
um
so with the with tiger what's the thing
with tiger like guys because I seen you
guys I met you at uh the golf at the
gulf what do you think of that man no
that [__] was dope that was fire yeah I
never been in no golf tournament or none
of that [__] like you said that [__] was
a big ass party that [__] was crazy bro
and they built that [__] it wasn't even
supposed to just use it as grass right
there and they built that thing that was
wow yeah that [__] was dope yeah and
that was Super Bowl weekend too yeah
yeah
um
have you gotten to meet some like rap
icons and stuff like that damn that's
crazy bro y'all met Tupac Mama bro
before she passed it was crazy
yeah that [__] was crazy and [__] and
then like I met Park Mama right so they
got the Grammy um
they was doing something it was Grammy
weekend and they had a a Tupac
um
I I think it was like a museum some with
the Grammys though and uh you feel me
like they wanted me to come speak you
feel me on the behalf of the
the the uh new generation at the time it
was like 2015. Wow and they wanted me to
come speak on them we have for the new
generation like Tupac impact
on us you you know the [__] who
grew up like
grew up listening a pop
when he passed I said you know right
um so
you know I'm saying I'll go I speak on
on like you send me the news generation
and just you know I'm saying how I felt
and and POC impact you know what I'm
saying and then uh people upset like I
said some [__] in his mama uh if she
came to me [__] it was like crying and
[__] she was like I love what you said
about my son
I'm like yeah yeah for sure and then she
just looking at me and she crying she
like they really killed my baby they
really killed my baby I'm like God damn
bro that [__] [__] me up cause like
I thought Park was alive
I thought was alive bro my whole but my
whole life bro I thought Park was alive
but that day that day I'm like nah bro
he gone duh his mama was crying in my
face no he's gone
yeah it was sad as [__] bro damn what'd
you do do you like holder or something
what was she was she really broken up
yeah no he was holding hands and [__]
like this you know what I'm saying but
no but it still really hurts her a lot
yeah yeah I mean I can't of course it
does because it's your child but still
for her to say that right in front of
you man that's powerful yeah I got a
picture I got a picture with her he beat
up we was talking and [__] oh if y'all
on Google Google what y'all on yeah I
think he can find it probably maybe YG
and uh Miss Shakur
funny
it's dope
I'm like damn I'm a park Mama wow and
had her crying
off the real shoot
you see me I just said some real [__] oh
that's cool bro
wow
that's legendary man yeah so when you
say rap like you know what I'm saying a
fine secure she like an icon you know
I'm saying rubber [__] Mama [__] you
feel me mean hurt I was big I was one of
the biggest little situations and then
I'm at like hole and [__]
um dang who else
and who's the most gangster person that
you've met really who's the realest
[__] you know what I'm saying is
he really you damn bro snooze
he got it
so night too you met him yeah no sir not
used to be
like Whitney and [__] pulling up to the
club you all that [__] and the water's
part for him probably huh huh people
don't play with him huh
like what you mean I mean I feel like it
would be when he shows up people get
real serious probably around him
like people are scared I'm scared
got a lot of [__] scared for
sure oh
man it's a lot of [__] who
cheat up bro you know
but you already met like damn near
everybody damn
I've been doing this [__] for a minute
though yeah I know
I know you have I'm trying to think did
you ever get to meet mystical or no no I
ain't met my school he was different huh
his whole style was kind of different
yeah musical was hard yeah for sure I've
seen him at a car wash once
and uh this is cool oh she wanted to say
what's up but I didn't I was embarrassed
on my car at the time and I didn't want
to see my [__] car
so I didn't even go over there bro I'll
cover my settings so let's do it so we
couldn't see it bro no you should have
embraced you should have said let's go
what's up hey I'm gonna be somebody one
day remember this [__] I'm telling you
yeah man and we used to listen who else
was in cash money I'm trying to think
they had uh
who's that other God they had
the BG remember him
BG yeah yeah for sure
Chopper City man he was this yeah I
remember bro too
yeah I really love Kim
hey what Hurricane Chris from
Hurricane Chris
hey
folks guys
from where Shreveport Louisiana oh yeah
I'm glad he made it out of there
Shreveport you know he just shot
somebody or some [__] recently oh dang
bro I think he murders some shitty
Flatline
looking unwell in that [__] too right
there
he ain't looking real well who's like
some of the hardest chicks that's coming
up you think
female sexy rig on brazy really yeah
dang I gotta see your blood from St
Louis she is yeah
sexy red let me see a look at her
sexy red huh sexy red ghetto
ghetto hood [__] oh that's what I like
boy oh yeah you like that huh I like
some of that [__] oh you you from New
Orleans I like their mother yeah
all right
I like some of that
I like it when that [__] is going on boy
oh yeah I like her she seems good sexy
red I'm have to check her out then yeah
bro oh you ever have some black ghetto
oh man I don't know about that oh
uh
I've been I mean I've been with them I
think mixed I think I've been waiting
I think what's the darkest woman you've
ever been with you think real dark yeah
I have some dark skinned women for sure
I love them
oh yeah dark chocolate damn boy pink oh
Pink as [__]
hey boy
well at least they healthy they sound
healthy
um I'm trying to think of what I like
yeah I think I would like
[Music]
yeah I would like maybe like a
like a nice black woman
um
what about Asian woman you like Asian
woman yeah
I I
ain't got no type yeah I'm like Ray
Sherman yeah I like them
whoa you got no type well you know
um what rapper would be a good preacher
as well you think or good pastor I'm
talking to somebody who would be like
the next TD Jakes you know what I'm
talking about
Snoop really yeah you gotta see me be a
man he playing that role in bed man he
did yeah I watch it all right he plays a
pastor
[Laughter]
no cap
damn look at him in there he looked like
a lean Jesse Jackson like an early
yesterday
wow
oh you know who would be a good pastor
who is it be kind of different would it
be good
Kanye West really oh yeah but he tried
it though I think did you ever go to one
of his Sunday Services nah but I was
watching this [__] on the internet and
shoot yeah
he was getting closed in the in uh the
RAP Community do people think that he
went crazy do people think that hey man
a rap Community we love Kanye yeah
you send me the black community RAP
Community
we love Kanye yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah he did so much I mean he's
he's such a uh Kanye is a [__] he's a
yeah I know you can't say that like that
but he is a [__] and we love him yeah I
think it's an almost you know he'll be
[__] up sometimes yeah
he said some [__] you know said he's
like God damn that was crazy but you
know what I'm saying we love you
yeah I think everybody love you you know
I think everybody wants the best for him
yeah man I think he's real creative I
just bought his shoes and then they said
you know what did you do after you
bought the shoes I kept them [__] I
still wanted okay okay for sure that's
how I support him you know I wish he'd
come back and make him again I enjoyed
him yeah I think he gonna do something
like that yeah so he'll figure it out I
think he's creative enough
um
what else man what other kind of
business you see yourself getting in man
what's the next Genesis huh yeah
I'm saying like some flaming hot ones
you know what I'm saying soon gang but
um
man I'm heavy in the TV in film space
right now I got some [__] I'm gonna
announce real soon
I was gonna announce it
when it first happened but you send me
the right of strike and [__] yeah so
y'all doing something new they got to
get that [__] right and then I'm gonna
announce you know I'm saying my
partnership and what I got going on and
um yeah
I'm heavy into the TV and film space
right now you know what I'm saying I got
my 400 brand
and I think can I get some of the 400
stuff I got some [__] here for you oh
God you know so I can walk again you can
do that [__] like walking in right now
yeah yeah let's see it bro hey bring the
400 in the building bring it in like in
a room and bring me that [__] Draco
too homie I'm gonna [__] shoot
something
you want to shoot some I know sorry I'm
fired up little boxes I always wanted to
be here oh damn bro really yeah bro oh
gang man gang [__] bro
that's what I [__] need if I do a
crime I'm doing it on this [__] yeah God
damn
I'm just saying boy if I do what I'm
crying bro I'm doing it in the [__]
nicest [__] oh wow that's height
you know what I'm saying that's for
winning man that's hype
oh and they got the red too
I hate when [__] pull up on me
empty-handed like [__] bring a
bottle or something look I'm gonna
remember that
yeah
yeah bro let me see what else we got
here it's like Christmas right here the
flame baby you're the flame bro oh wow
these are real shoes huh hey wear my
[__] like you wear the [__] Yeezys
and [__] yeah man I'll wear these baby
you know I'm saying look at the bottom
look at the soul oh
that's nice boy
um yeah cocaine wipes is it really yeah
I used to do that cocaine baby damn
I [__] be out there doing it did you
ever like it Coke yeah
um I don't think I ever tried it it's
not a is it a hood is cocaine or like a
do people do cocaine in the hood is it
real popular or no yeah people do Coke
in the hood yeah it's popular damn it's
popular as [__]
what kept you off of it you think do you
see somebody that you just saw the
effects of it it just wasn't your thing
it's never been your thing no I like I
just I don't even remember me doing it
I thought I asked one of my homies if I
ever tried
what about mushrooms right you see a lot
of brothers doing mushrooms now bro what
you think of all of that because a lot
no bro
yeah it is but you think it's
when I was growing they didn't have a
lot of brothers wasn't doing LSD
mushrooms and that kind of [__] they
didn't want that magic in them you know
yeah okay no it's a lot it's a lot of
brothers it's a lot of blacks it's a lot
of [__] in the hood doing
mushrooms that's what's up bro yeah
because that's good for your braces like
it expands your mind bro it's crazy like
my homies and [__] like they'd be like
yeah I'm off the shrooms I'm like damn
y'all [__] doing shrooms all right
back
like twice
did you like it one time I was in the
studio and [__] and the walls was moving
and [__] and I was trying to like record
and [__] I was like
standing you send me the mic right here
and then a wall right behind the mic so
like like I'm just looking at the wall
trying to rap and this [__] was like
moving and [__] I had to leave I'm like
nah I gotta go yeah and then I was up
all night talking like about like space
and the aliens and [__] yeah weird [__]
I'm like I'm like yeah no I can't do
this [__]
hey bro I just gotta stick with my
alcohol you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah that's the thing man yeah I think
mushroom make you really
because we did a bunch of a bunch of LSD
one time and we went to the
um Waffle House right there at Waffle
House in our town so he went there and
we was all you know we were squirreling
bro we was [__] you know like that
looking like Tweakers oh we look like a
couple of [__] squirrels look like
two squirrels in that [__] and we never
uh and they had a gay gentleman that
worked in there and he was a um he was
the waiter and we never met a gay dude
before we'd heard about him but we never
met one and we were laughing so hard
um he thought my buddy was choking right
so he starts doing a heimlich maneuver
on my buddy bro and we [__] probably
never see nothing
so anyway that was something good
I'm trying to meet you remember the
first white person you ever met or not
first white person I ever met
um
nah like I guess it's so diverse bro
yeah School
I'm trying to remember the first black
guy I ever met
dude I remember the first time I went to
a black doctor right I went to a doctor
and I'd never been to a black doctor and
we thought about it right and I went in
it was a black Doctrine I was like oh
[__] man like
is he gonna know what's wrong with me
no but I saw like some racist [__] I
know what I'm saying like
I didn't mean like oh wow but here's
what it made me think it made me think
that when I was growing up all my black
friends had to go to White doctors and I
was like [__] I wonder if they ever went
in there and thought how's this dude
just because you know just because of
what times like how's this dude gonna
know what's wrong with me no so hey so
like now
when I'll be going to the doctor I want
a black doctor yeah because
see if you're a doctor
you feel me y'all all went to school
y'all learned the same [__] nothing you
know what I'm saying you probably a
little smarter than this [__] or
you specialize in this ah whatever
whatever right but when it comes down to
it
[Music]
I feel like
because I'm so like tapped in into the
world and [__] now and just people and
[__] like I'm like I want a black doctor
because I'm a black person so if I got a
black doctor I feel like he gonna care
about me and what I got going on more so
I need a black doctor yeah that's the
type of [__] I'm on
in my life and it ain't really on no
racial [__] it's just like you feel me
like
that's just how humans I don't know I
feel like
like if I'm a black dude
and I walk in the [__] doctor office
the black person don't care about my
situation Mo to anybody else good point
you know well it makes sense that you
would that anybody would think that way
and if he has a if he had like I think
yeah well when I was growing up they
didn't have like a lot of black folks
didn't have you didn't have a black like
in our town we didn't have a black
doctor right we had assistant principal
teachers some black teachers but they
just didn't have it you know like it was
in Louisiana they just didn't have it
yet so it was just crazy man I just
never thought damn I never even been to
a black doctor and then I walked in one
day and it was a black doctor I was like
damn I don't even know how to do this
and he was cool as [__] oh he was cool I
was just I was I was like damn and then
I started thinking yeah what if people
had gone had their whole life they had
to go to White doctors would they ever
think that they were being they might
think they aren't being cared for
properly yeah it was just interesting
thoughts you know have you been in an
accident have you been damaged up check
your body is something broken is
something missing that's the you're like
whoa jeepers
no wonder I'm late to work I don't have
a limb
well Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm
if someone has done you wrong
well what are you gonna do
being fair is very important to me
Morgan and Morgan they have over 100
offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting to get
you full and fair compensation
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as as washing your thighs
baby warm water and good soap Free Soap
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
that's right could be a car accident
could have been something happen at work
fairness is important
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone that's
forthepeople.com slash this past weekend
or dial pound law pound 529 from your
cell this is a paid advertisement
but he was cool man
um
but I'm trying to think of what else we
could think about oh a lot of people say
that there's beef between black folks
and aliens and [__] do you you hear a
lot about that hell no bro I don't know
nothing about it
I don't think nobody ever seen anything
bro I think that [__] really yeah for
real
why don't more black people see aliens
I don't think no people seen anything so
you think a lot of people just they cap
and they're lying very Kevin bro
[__] cat you think why because
they're just lonely or bored
[__] is just [__] just
because this [__]
like
have you seen the alien I never have
you know somebody who seen one
I don't exactly
yeah
yeah you're right about that
have you seen the UFO
um
[Music]
no exactly you've seen it
um
that's the thing
and I think black people would see them
morphing because they're black people
outside a lot
don't say enough
oh that was the funniest [__] everybody
would see him bro we all saw it up they
would probably see them first right I
don't know because
white people outside more than us
because
you should maybe 10 in this [__] yeah
that's a good point bro but that's
daytime no that's daytime man what they
gotta do with a UFO that's a good point
man a lot of you are you gonna go see
them at night yeah well I think a lot of
them they seem to get out more at night
see nah man that's [__] yeah because
we see we see our airplanes fly during
the daytime
that's true bro
um
so when so like do you have a like a new
plan for Wednesday when's your stuff
with tiger gonna come out do you have a
plan or is this kind of you taking it as
it comes I mean that [__] coming out
like August September you know what I'm
saying but you know um
we got the tour you know what I'm saying
oh y'all touring yeah me him and sweetie
going on tour oh you know uh as long as
this interview come out after next
Tuesday is good okay okay we can do that
all right yeah
I'm saying we're doing a little run and
this will be your first tour since
pandemic huh nah I did I did um I did
like a run top of this year like January
February I did it wrong
uh do you like going out on tour y'all
love it yeah yeah I like like you know
what I'm saying I'm like the dude who
like partying and [__] you know yeah you
like to have a good time
you ever party with six nine that guy no
you know what I'm talking about that
Rainbow Guy no bro
no
what about
um
Brian McKnight
what about
Jodeci ever met them
um how about met them
I don't know I don't know if I think so
but uh I don't know if I have either
um I mean I've seen you met like Donald
Trump or something I saw him at the
fight last weekend Oh last weekend yeah
I saw with the fights the other day
we'll fight with you yeah I met he was
at the UFC have you been to UFC
I've been on fire you gotta come with me
sometime man you can I'll be watching
them [__] them [__] is crazy as [__] bro
you would love it there bro hey last
week bro that was like two months ago
oh I've saw him last week too who fought
last week
um this guy volkanovsky and another guy
yair Rodriguez where the the headliners
and uh
yeah but I met him two times
yeah do black people [__] with him more
it seems like it to me it seemed like
more black guys would mess with Trump
because he seems more
like connected to the culture a little
bit hey look I ain't gonna lie bro
the black community was not [__] with
Trump you know what I'm saying
but when that PPP [__] and all that [__]
came out mm-hmm
black people forgave them
because he helped out yeah
I'm speaking on the [__] in the
hood and [__] yeah I'm speaking on abs
you hear me let them tell it if I mean
that's what they say yeah
she
buying ain't dead enough for us because
the [__] Trump was passing out money we
[__] with Chuck I'm like this are y'all
back with Trump just like that huh he
was like [__] like hell yeah they were
passing out money
I'm like dude that [__] crazy bruh
that's true though somebody showed up
with a couple of bucks man that'll
change the way you think about them yeah
so yeah I thought it was interesting I
mean I didn't speak with him too much
but his son was there
I don't know I mean you know
I don't know how I mean I have different
I don't really trust a lot of these cats
you know I never really liked politics I
never trusted I never really trusted
politics man I never because we grew up
in like a poor area so if something was
happening in our area
nobody cared because we weren't paying
him taxes you know we didn't have a lot
of tax money so
they weren't really coming to help us
you know hey so would you tell them when
you met him
Trump yeah I asked him if he thought I
could be a working pot if if he thought
I could work in politics one day
yeah
no he didn't but he's like yes you can
hear the best thing about Trump I will
say this right he's like you're doing
great you're fine you're good he goes
your parents are great I was like my dad
been there for 30 years
he got bullshitter no but he goes but
before that he was doing good
he like makes you feel you know he's
just good at shaking he just makes you
feel excited you know
um but he was real friendly he rolled in
with Mike Tyson man the first time that
I met him which was crazy and then uh
but yeah he seemed to be doing good
um who who did uh oh I did sit next to
his son one time because his son looks
kind of like a business guy you know you
know I make the biggest [__] Trump song
ever
[__] Donald Trump that was your song
dude no way bro yeah bro you know that I
didn't even know that you think I was
being lip [__] damn bro
congratulations so I wanted to like what
are you gonna like if I ever met a [__]
like what are you gonna say look at me
he probably like it's a good song
because it was a good song he would at
least give you that credit you know all
right hey he's funny as hell he would at
least I think give you that credit man
but uh yeah I don't know sometimes yeah
it's interesting politics is interesting
because you start to see like if certain
communities are just being used if
certain communities are just being uh
taken advantage of you know
um but
anyway man
uh
I'm trying to think of anything else we
want to talk about but I thought that he
was nice though he was nice yeah but
it's you know I don't know him I don't
know what he's like as a
business person and everything but he
seemed to just sit there and enjoy the
fights you know and grabbing business by
their [__] and [__] too right I mean
who a lot of people
who knows
[Laughter]
uh dishwashing gloves that were just
like that bro
well yeah I do damn
you man he did yeah he was grabbing
people by the [__] man yeah
but yeah and I guess some people don't
want they don't want that
they want you to just you know tap them
yeah and yeah he was doing it
what kind of women do you prefer you
have a you know you don't have no type
oh
I like what I like you know man oh yeah
I like if I see it and I like it I like
it yup and you like a long woman like a
small woman
um like how you just said that [__]
don't sound right at all so yeah right
about that yeah
oh did you ever get to meet Boosie
that's the last question
real [__] I had Boosie when he was
fresh out of jail I hadn't pulled up in
the hood on the Block really yeah he
pulled up you know I'm saying hopped out
you feel me on Rosecrans all this chains
on you feel me hit hit Oleander then hit
Spruce yeah walk up on the Block y'all
said the homies like hey
what's up [__] Boosie pull up you feel
me like yeah what's up [__] fresh shout
out like yeah [__]
it was like 2014 or something though
yeah I remember dude yeah because he got
out right around Easter bro and I
remember I put a tweet out of it said he
is risen bro like the day he got out I
was so yeah we grew up off Boosie bruh
dude I could be in the worst mood bro I
put on bro we used to ride [__]
that used to be our our hype song or
warm up song said it off in this
[__] said it all right
it was bad bro so y'all had warm-up
music for robberies yeah bro you know
when you going around you riding around
you scoping some [__] off
get out
in Louisiana you put that on there could
be anything going on bro robbery murder
burial whatever bro wedding you turn on
that [__] song Everything Changes bro
people [__] having a blast man that's
that's the one thing I love about Boosie
he does it Boosie's real too man he came
in here yeah Boosie real [__] he
came in here
and uh we had it we had a really nice
time I really just
yeah I think he's a neat guy yeah no for
sure you gotta appreciate [__]
like Boosie bro you know oh yeah we need
more [__] like Boosie he rolled
up he got extremely high I remember and
then he went outside and he opened the
car door and a couple they had a bunch
of like luggage and stuff in there but
they had a couple [__] rolled out the
luggage and they was dancing oh yeah
that's dope yeah it was I thought it was
really cool
um YG we got these new items bro thank
you so much man yeah bro I'm gonna um
I'm working on on on a new product you
know what I'm saying is going to come
out through my 400 brand
um like my homies be taking a lot of
like
like you know them them uh like them sex
pills from the gas station rhinos and
[__] bro you know they're not good for
you oh the ones make my legs sweat I'm
working on some all-natural sex pills
this is all natural you know what I'm
saying
so all natural [__] and I'm gonna put
them all through the brand and [__] you
know you know I'm inspired
by the by the homies and [__] cause I'm
like bro y'all can't keep y'all gonna
have like like heart problems and [__]
later on are they taking a lot of them I
mean I like I don't like who knows a lot
yeah like who knows was a lot you could
take tear like who knows like you know
what I'm saying so it's like nah bro let
me go figure should I offer to go put
something together you know so uh hey
when I get through you know I'm saying I
got the final product be a trial dude
bro I'll be a a trial tester for them
nah we already got the testing and [__]
going how the testing go good yeah it's
all natural bro it's all natural [__] no
side images I'll tell you something I
might take one if I'm even going to the
market or anything if I'm going just to
I go to Ross Dress for Less bro to have
a little bit of pump on me
I like that [__] I like walking in but
[__] crazy I'm serious
I'm serious dude you get a little bit
amped up bro you rolling I don't want to
know about none of that but I'm just
saying bro you rather roll in like this
or like that you halfway to the [__]
you have to wait I want to know about
none of that you don't want to sell on
the pills bro yeah that's the pill for
you know I'm saying whenever you want to
do what you want to do yeah that's
intimacy you know what I'm saying that's
that Valentine I care about my people
you know is there a lot of natural is
there a lot of erectile dysfunction in
the black community
[Laughter]
because like obviously like you feel me
I think [__] be [__] a lot and you
know they do like [__] be
trying to they be having like a lot of
different women they trying to keep it
going just like make that first
impression on just smack it down you
know what I'm saying and you know the
homies be out here [__] oh they
[__] a lot so it's like you know what
I'm saying
I'm inspired to make this [__] you feel
me
because you feel me the homies but yeah
like it's gonna be a product for
everybody natural and natural will it be
a gum will it be a tablet you know sex
sale oh yeah so sexual baby think about
crazy like the Trojan condoms you know
what I'm saying be a billionaire
yeah and if you had this nice pill and
so is the pillow natural is it a tablet
is it a gum oh no this appeals a capsule
okay
or even a nasal spray I would do that
[__] boy nasal spray get a couple pumps
of that no that ain't classy you know
what I'm saying that's true yeah you got
it
you know what I'm saying yeah you got to
be discreet about it yeah discreet
classic you know what I'm saying but
I'ma give it to you so you can test it
out damn
I'm about to get it seem like a wild
[__] like you know what I'm
saying so like oh thanks you so I'm
gonna give you the pill and you let me
know
did it work or not all right yeah I take
them a lot man and I'll tell you this
also buddy um that uh
because I've here the worst part is if
you take one right you go on a date you
take one and then your date says I don't
I'm not having a nice time on this date
I'm going home
then you out there you really I mean I
drink alcohol bro I just get faded yeah
but I'm just saying if you take a pill
you get amped up a little bit and then
the lady goes home you lurk then you now
you out in the town you lurking see
that's why I just drink alcohol yeah
because [__] going straight to sleep
you know that yeah yeah
oh you ain't pulling up good night
yeah man that's uh
that's nice to have do you have a
preference of alcohol you said I'm a
tequila uh Drinker you know yeah yeah
heavy on a tequila really heavy on a
tequila light on the ice yeah why did
they do light ice a lot of brothers do
light ice what is it because I got
enough phone anyway dang camera let's go
boy
uh 400 thank you for coming in YG I
appreciate you man yeah I'm excited to
try the pills man I take them regularly
no shame in my [__] bro and if I can get
natural on some [__]
if I get one of those brother uppers and
I'm on that [__] dog I'll take that
[__] dog it's like ginseng and other
like [__] like that you could put as
much gin in as you want bro I'll [__]
take that [__] son
um I'm excited about it uh but yeah
thanks for the gifts man and thanks for
pulling up no man appreciate you for
having me again yeah and uh we're
looking forward to the new music man yep
coming soon gang baby best of luck yeah
thank you you too
[Music]
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of mine I found I can
feel it in my bones
[Music]